hey guys so i'm off to do a little photo
shoot with jenna we're gonna get some
photos taken for some little projects
that we're working on and i just got my
mail and in the mail the box
specifically says this box
contains
i justine do not open until june 2nd
2015. well
i think since i am
myself that i think that i'm allowed to
open it so i'm going to give myself full
permission to open the said box
well we know i'm not going to use this
for cooking let's see what we got in
here
i am opening myself
oh my gosh it's actually
it's the audio they're the audio cds
holy moly so because it's a hardcover
they also do audio well it's going to be
an audiobook but the hardcover does the
audio cds like this is an actual cd with
my voice i'm really nervous to hear what
it sounds like being a youtuber it's
weird because obviously you think i'd be
used to hearing my own voice but the
sound of it and editing
i don't want to hear it any longer do
not open
yeah i'm gonna do it anyway
it's more audio oh my gosh well i'm
gonna have to do some giveaways for
those bad boys also in the mail i'm so
excited about this so this website
called framebridge they contacted me
like hey you might want to check out our
service we do really cool framed photos
of like your instagram photos or
facebook or whatever and
i'm not gonna lie like i wasn't
necessarily skeptical but i was a little
skeptical because i've seen a bunch of
these framing services before and they
didn't really turn out like this well
you can choose from so many freaking
different frames and this photo right
here is one that i took while i was in
san bruno at youtube so this is like on
their steps it says is this real life
it's from one of the youtube videos
where uh david after the dentist gets
his dental procedure i'm not actually
sure what he ever got done but anyway
here it is it's called frame bridge i'll
put a link in the description if you
guys want to check it out they're
actually giving you guys 15 off if you
use i just need to check out and if you
do please send me a picture of your
final frame because they have so many
different frames to pick from and i
clearly have a thing about shiny
mirrored styles so this is the one that
i picked but i want to get a couple more
because i don't have any art in my house
and it's kind of really sad
look at that is this art that is not art
what are you so anyway i gotta go to the
shoot i got oh my god look at these what
the heck am i gonna do so many
so many
okay um arch your back and lean forward
just a little bit more so you get more
shape there you go good
so we're at the shoot we've done a bunch
of really fun looks francesca did our
hair and makeup and you did jenna's hair
makeup for the first time first time and
i think she's never even had her makeup
done ever i don't think she has actually
she looks so pretty i don't look good in
this light oh you do it actually was
amazing
perfect
it does look very cute
and we get a little smoky
jen looks so cute i'm gonna grab my next
wardrobe here
all right our shoot is over i feel like
i have so much makeup on francesco i
just can't believe it they're going to
say just he has so much makeup on
they're cute
for a photo shoot yeah it's first shoot
this isn't for life jogging not going
jogging
nope how's the photos
oh i'm so excited to see the makeup it
looks good
come on now
let's okay peanut gallery on a date with
i just oh my gosh what's the next
contest make sure to follow her on
twitter oh come on dinner
oh thanks you're so sweet
we're not supposed to have any days
excuse me i'm gonna take a meeting now
well i'm gonna go take a meeting now
i'm getting ready to post this picture
what's your instagram uh mr vinnie
m-r-v-i-n-n-y
follow me there's some followers yay go
follow him and leave him some comments
and
maybe leave some suggestions on
something else that we should do like a
fun shoot maybe um what i should wear
what color make okay oh okay come on now
i'm in the commenters
okay i'm gonna pack up my stuff and i'll
see you guys later bye
you